the new gender switch is expected to
sell 40 million systems by the end of
2020 according to a recent report from
research firm DFC intelligence selling
forty million systems would make the
switch almost three times as successful
as the Wii U which sold 13 point 36
million units comparatively the way sold
100 million units over the course of its
lifetime Nintendo has said it will have
two million Nintendo switch units
available worldwide for its launch month
DFC indicated that the switch may not
see a particularly strong start as a
result of the allocated stock available
at launch and the relatively limited
launch lineup the report explains demand
is expected to be strong adding the
switch is a compelling piece of hardware
that could potentially reach a much
larger addressable market however given
the limited software and Nintendo's poor
recent track record of introducing new
products we have tempered our forecasts
to be conservative this which arrives on
march three for three hundred dollars
for all the latest on this one and
everything else that matters in gaming
stay tuned to games flood
Oh